confidence that you have in any  situation whether it's negotiation  dating sales is directly proportional to  the amount of quality options you have  at your disposal and so that means is  you win the negotiations you win the  circumstance by creating options for  yourself before you enter the room it's  not about the tactics and the hooks and  the whatever it's realizing that you  don't need this customer because you've  got others it's realizing that you don't  need this girl because there are others  out there and it's realizing that you  don't need this deal that you really  want because there are other options  that are just as good out there and so  you win the negotiations you win the  circumstances by doing the work before  you walk in the room